The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITOpenCourseWare@OCW.MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome.
One quick announcement--
if you have not yet
picked up your graded
exams, you can do so
by seeing the TAs
after the hour.
OK?
So today I want to
continue to think
about what we started last week,
thinking about Fourier series.
The idea is to
develop a theory that
lets us look at signals on the
basis of frequency content,
much as we looked at
frequency responses
as a characterization
of systems,
according to the way
they process frequencies.
And we saw last time that
there were a number of kinds
of signals, for example,
musical signals,
where that kind of
an on approach--
thinking about the signal
according to the frequencies
that are in it--
makes a lot of sense
and can lead to insight.
We also developed
some formalism.
We figured out how you can
break a signal into components
and then assemble the components
to generate the signal.
And what I want to mention at
the beginning of the hour today
is just how to think
about this operation
in a more familiar way.
We do this kind of a
thing, breaking something
into components all the time.
One of the more
familiar examples
might be thinking
about 3-space, right?
The Cartesian analysis of
3-space is based on the idea
that you can think about a
vector location in 3-space
as having components.
There's a component in
the x direction, the y
direction, the z direction.
That's completely
analogous to the way
we're thinking about Fourier
representations for signals.
So just like we would
think about synthesizing
the location of a point by
adding together three pieces,
and we would think about
analyzing a point to figure out
how big the components are
in each of those directions,
it's exactly the same when we
think about Fourier series.
We think about representing
a signal as a sum of things.
So the sum is
precisely the same.
This one happens to have an
infinite number of terms,
[? eh. ?] The top one has
three terms, [? eh. ?]
The principles are very similar.
So we think about representing
a signal as a sum of components.
We think about representing
a point in 3-space
as a sum of components,
and we think
about analyzing the signal
or the vector in 3-space,
so that we figure out what
each of those components are.
And we do it in an operation
where it's actually
very convenient to think
about the decomposition
of the Fourier components using
precisely the same language
that we would use for
thinking about vector spaces.
So we would think about--
in the case of the
Fourier, we think
about integrating over the
period sifts out a component.
The analogous
operation for 3-space
is to think about a dot product.
The way you take a
vector and figure out
the component in the x
direction is to dot it
with it, the dot product.
In the Fourier case,
we think about it
as being an inner product.
The idea is
completely analogous.
So we think about having the
inner product of two things--
the reference direction
and the vector.
So reference
direction and vector--
we think about it exactly
the same way, except now it's
an inner product, which means
that after we've multiplied,
we have to integrate.
That's the only difference
between inner product.
Inner product implies some are
[? integrated ?] after you've
done the multiplication.
So we do exactly the same
thing, except that now we
think about the inner
product of a and b.
That's just the integral, where
we take the complex conjugate
of one of the signals only
because by defining it
with a complex conjugate there,
we set up the inner product
so that the answer
is zero unless we
take the inner product of two
things in the same direction.
OK?
By putting the minus sign
there, if the two reference
directions, that
is to say the one
characterized by k and m, the
ones characterized by k and m,
the inner product
will be zero if we
take the complex conjugate as
long as k is not equal to m.
k equals m is the only
not zero component.
OK, is that all clear?
So to make sure that it's
clear, here's a question.
How many of the following
pairs of functions
are orthogonal in T equals 3?
Part of the goal
of the exercise is
to figure out what the little
caveat in T equals three means.
So look at your neighbor,
say hello, figure out
a number between 0 and 4.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
OK, so how many signals,
how many of the pairs
are orthogonal to each other?
Raise your hand with some
number between 0 and 4,
unless you're completely
bizarre and raise five, I mean.
OK, come on, come on.
Higher, so I can see them.
Remember if you're wrong.
It's your partner's fault,
it's not your fault.
OK, not quite.
A lot of bad partners, no, no.
Let's do the first one.
Is the cos of 2 pi t
orthogonal to the sine
of 2 pi t over the interval
capital T equals 3?
Yes?
No.
I haven't a clue.
I don't care.
No, no, no, no.
You all care, no.
Are they orthogonal?
So what do you--
how do I formally
ask the question are
they are orthogonal?
OK, so it's either the last
slide or the next slide.
So go back to the last slide.
What's it mean if
they're orthogonal?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So how do I
take the dot product?
What do I do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] conjugate.
PROFESSOR: Conjugate 1.
So I want to--
I'm thinking about 1 over T, the
integral over T, a star of T,
b of t, dt.
Right?
So the t comes in
here, right, I'm
integrating over a period t.
So I take the two functions
and I multiply them together.
So I have this function,
and I have that function.
I multiply them together.
If you multiply two sinusoids
of the same frequency
but different phase,
what do you get?
Another sinusoid, right?
So you all know all these
complicated trig relationships,
right?
Here's one of them.
If you multiply cos of 2
pi T times the sine of pi T
you get half the sign
of double the frequency.
OK?
You don't need to memorize that.
You just look at this picture,
you look at that picture.
This one over the
interval 3 has 3 periods.
Right?
There are 3 periods
of that waveform
over the period of
capital T. There's
an integer number 3, same here.
Here-- how many periods?
Twice that.
But it's exactly six.
So you get a pure sinusoid.
You get an integer
number of periods.
You integrate over an integer
number of periods, you get 0.
They're orthogonal.
Had I chosen the
period differently,
they may not have
been orthogonal.
It depends on the period.
OK?
So the inner product
depends on the period,
because the inner
product has something
to do with integrator sum.
And so the range over which
you sum or integrate matters.
How about cos 2 pi T cos 4 pi T?
Orthogonal?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: And the reason is?
AUDIENCE: So think if you
wrapped [INAUDIBLE] together,
then there's a lot
of symmetry that
goes on [INAUDIBLE]
is going to be 0.
PROFESSOR: So now we've got
two different frequencies.
But we still get these
funny cosine relationships
that have to do with
sums and differences.
And the sums and
differences both
happen to be periodic over
3, over the interval capital
T equals 3, right?
So we still get the property
that the average value here,
which is what the interval was
pulling out, the average is 0.
So they're also orthogonal.
How about cos 2 pi T sine pi T?
OK, I've asked two questions,
and they were both yes.
So I'm getting
bored at this point,
so by the theory of questions
in lecture, the answer is?
[LAUGHTER]
Now, wait a minute.
I'm not that boring.
Well, maybe.
So is this periodic over
a capital T equals 3?
Ah, excuse me.
I didn't say the
right question, sorry.
Is this function have an integer
number of periods in the time
interval capital T equals 3?
What's the period-- what's
the fundamental period
of this waveform?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
So it has 3 periods over
the interval cap T equals 3.
What about this one?
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: Period is 2.
How many periods are there in
the time interval capital T
equals 3?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: A period is 2.
How many periods are there--
1 and 1/2, not an integer.
Bad news, right?
So integer number three,
not integer number.
If you were to integrate
this over the period t
equals 3, if I
didn't multiply them
if I just did that, if I just
thought about that integral,
I wouldn't get 0, right?
There's more positives
than there are negatives.
And when I multiply them, the
same sort of thing happens.
I get two big peaks down
and only one big peak up.
It's because the resulting
waveform no longer
has an integer number of periods
in the interval capital T
equals 3.
OK?
Last one-- cos 2 pi T e to the--
whoops.
Is that what I actually said?
Good, I forgot the j.
Because without the j,
they would obviously not
be orthogonal.
Obviously, right?
OK.
I didn't mean to ask
something quite that obvious.
So what about cos 2 pi
T and e to the j 2 pi T?
Orthogonal.
Not, I'm as clueless as I was
on Part A. No, no, no, no,
you're not.
No, you're not.
So how do you think about that?
You can use Euler's expression.
And if there had
been a j there, this
would have been a
correct expression.
OK?
It's not quite a
correct expression
because I forgot
to put the j there.
But had there been
a j there, it would
have been cos 2 pi T
plus j sine 2 pi T.
And the awkward thing is
that the cos and the cos
are obviously not
orthogonal with each other.
A signal is not orthogonal
with itself, OK?
So because part of this
signal is that signal,
those two signals
are not orthogonal.
OK?
Yes?
OK, so that's kind
of-- so that's
the idea of orthogonality.
It's a very good way to
think about decompositions.
And even though we only spent
about half an hour last time,
and only about 15
minutes this time,
that is the whole theory
of Fourier series.
That doesn't mean we
can't ask hard questions.
There were a couple
of questions.
Yes, you were first.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way to
think about orthogonality
using the Fourier [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, the
Fourier coefficients
are the result of orthogonality.
I don't think you
can tell-- if I just
told you a bunch of
Fourier coefficients,
I don't know if you
can tell me something
about the orthogonality of
the underlying signals or not.
AUDIENCE: What if [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? the period ?]
and the Fourier [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's see,
so I'm not completely
sure I know what you're asking.
Certainly if you tell me that
the Fourier's coefficients are
blah, blah, blah,
3, 2 7, and 16.
And if you tell me that you're
working with a simple Fourier
series periodic in 3, then
you've told me everything.
And so there's a way
for me to backtrack
that it was orthogonal.
I am not sure if I'm connecting
with you, so if I'm not,
ask me after lecture
to make sure that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I think
he's saying if you
have two signals [INAUDIBLE]
coefficients [INAUDIBLE] two
signals, can I tell if those
two signals are orthogonal
[INAUDIBLE] the coefficients
are orthogonal [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: If they have
components in common,
they couldn't possibly
be orthogonal.
So I would answer
yes to that question.
So if that's what you were-- so
I think that's probably right.
Does that sound right?
Yeah, OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm awfully confused
by the complex conjugate,
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: So does that mean
we're taking the complex
conjugate [? of a ?] and
we're [? applying it ?] to b?
PROFESSOR: We're taking
the complex conjugate
of the entire function.
At every point in time, we take
the complex conjugate of it.
And it's especially
useful to think about
if you're doing
something of the form--
if a of t were e to the
j 2 pi mt and if b of t
were e to the j 2 pi lt.
The only thing
we're trying to do--
but this comes up
quite frequently--
the only thing
we're trying to do
is when you conjugate
one of these,
you rig it so that when
you add the exponents,
the result goes to 0 by
putting the minus up there.
That's all.
AUDIENCE: It
doesn't seem like we
had to do any of that for the
example we just worked on.
It seems like there were just
like [? signals ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Oh, interesting.
That's a very good point.
That's interesting.
So I didn't intend to
throw you a ringer.
These were signals, all
of these except that one,
are real functions of time.
That's why the complex
conjugate didn't come up.
So I apologize.
I wasn't trying to
make it seem tricky.
OK, so it's because
this function of time
is everywhere real that we
didn't need to rehearse this.
We did have to do
it in that one.
OK?
OK, so the point is that
we've already covered,
even though we've only done a
little bit of work in lecture,
we've already covered
all of the theory.
What remains though is
to do some practice.
And also what remains is to
understand how this is useful.
So it's not just music.
The example that I want to
talk about today is speech.
The same sort of thing that we
could do with music last time,
we can do with speech.
And here are some utterances.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Bat, bait, bet, beet, bit,
bite, bought, boat, but, boot.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: All
right, it was just
intended to be a bunch of
sounds that we can analyze
with Fourier analysis to
get some insight into how
to think about, in particular,
speech recognition and speech
synthesis.
So we can take those
utterances, and all
I did was write a little Python
program to do the decomposition
that I showed on
the previous slides,
so that I could break
these time waveforms.
Here I'm illustrating one, two,
three, four, five, six periods.
So I took one
period of that sound
and ran it through that
kind of an integral
to break it into Fourier
components, which
are showed here.
And what I want
you to see is just
like you could have
recognized a pattern here,
and you might try to
recognize which vowel is which
by the signature in time.
An alternative, and
far more useful way
of thinking about it,
is to try to recognize
the pattern in frequency.
So there are characteristic
differences in the sounds,
and we'll look at the
basis for why there are.
There are characteristic
differences
in the sound that can help
us to identify automatically,
by a machine, what
was being said.
And so what we
want to do is learn
to think about a pattern
that characterizes ah,
ee, oo in the frequency domain,
as opposed to the time domain.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Bat beet, boot.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So there's something
different about those sounds
that manifests a difference
in this Fourier signature.
So that's one of the useful
applications of this.
And we'd like to
understand that better.
There's a really good physical
reason why that happens.
And it has to do with the
way we produce speech.
So you can think about speech as
being generated by some source.
Ultimately, the
source of my speech
is somewhere down here,
which always amuses me
when I see the cut off heads
talking, like at Halloween
and like on some cartoon shows.
Because you can't
do that, right?
Because the source has to
do with down here someplace,
right?
My lungs push in.
That pushes air
through something
and starts making noise somehow.
I'm going to focus today on
things that we call voiced--
in a voiced sound.
Ah, in a voiced sound,
it's caused by vibrations
of the vocal chords.
So if you were to stick a
camera down someone's throat,
this is the sort of
thing that you would see.
It's an enormously
complex structure
whose mechanics are extremely
difficult to understand.
Because what happens is when
you want to make a high sound,
you tense the structure.
You pull on some muscles
that pull the cords.
The cords are normally
rattling pretty fast.
And what you do is,
you pull on a muscle
that tenses them to
make it go higher.
But your intuition should
say, now wait a minute--
you're making it longer
to make it higher?
And your intuition
would be right.
Normally, long organ pipes are
higher or lower in frequency?
AUDIENCE: Lower.
PROFESSOR: Lower.
So you have to do a lot
of mental calculations
in order to move these
muscles correctly.
So that the resulting
frequency of the vibration
comes out right.
It's not obvious,
because two things
happen as you tense the muscle.
The folds-- the vocal cords get
longer which you would think
would make the frequency
lower, but they
get tighter, which, of course,
goes the other direction,
right?
So it's a very
complicated thing.
And in fact, it's
something that goes
bad with professional speakers.
But even more,
professional singers
often have a lot of trouble
with the enormous stress
that happens on this structure
with repeated use and repeated
overuse.
Anyway, this takes
a real beating.
But that's ultimately
the source of speech.
But if that were all you
had, it wouldn't sound much
like speech.
A lot of the interesting stuff
comes from these cavities
that you intentionally
manipulate
as you're speaking to make
the different characteristic
sounds.
So the idea then is that you
have a source that contains
information like frequency.
What's the pitch
of the utterance?
But you have this other thing,
which is acting like a filter.
If you think about the
whole thing as a system,
we have a block which
represents a filter, which
is the thing that has
a frequency response.
The frequency response
depends on how
I've put my tongue in my mouth
and how I've opened my lips
and stuff like that.
We'll see that in a minute.
But it also depends on
how the vocal folds--
it has an input, which
is the vocal folds.
So the idea then is the same
kind of a source filter idea
that we motivated last time by
way of the RC filter example.
If you put a resistor
and a capacitor
together with a source,
a convenient way
to think about that is
as a low pass filter.
We think about it having
a frequency response.
So the system, just the RC
part, has a frequency response
which we can characterize
by a Bode diagram.
So we can think about--
we did this last time--
so we can think about the
low frequencies go through
without attenuation.
The gain is 1, and
the phase is 0.
So basically low frequencies
go through the filter
without any change.
High frequencies are attenuated.
The higher the
frequency, the more
the attenuation, and phase
shifted by lagging pi over 2.
So that's a way of thinking
about the RC circuit
as a low pass filter.
And it gives us
insight in the kinds
of signals that go through
and don't go through.
So that, if we think about
a signal like a square wave
having a Fourier
series decomposition,
it only has odd components and
the odd components fall with k.
The magnitude of the
component is inverse with k.
So we get components that,
if I plot on a log scale,
the reciprocal relationship of
the weight of the components,
the magnitude of the components,
makes it a straight line
with a slope of minus 1.
And now we can think about
putting this signal into the RC
filter and thinking about what
the output should look like.
If the frequency
of the square wave,
if the fundamental
frequency, 2 pi
over the period, if
2 pi over capital T,
if 2 pi over capital T is some
frequency that's low compared
to the corner frequency
of the low pass filter,
basically the output
of the filter, which
is showed in green, overlaps the
input, which is showed in red.
You can't tell the difference
because all the components
have the same magnitude
and phase as the input.
But if you change the
frequency of the square wave
so that the
fundamental is higher,
some of the higher
frequencies are attenuated
and phase shifted.
The shape of the
waveform, showed in green,
starts to deviate.
If you go to still
higher frequencies,
the deviation's even greater.
And if you go to high
enough frequencies,
they're all in the region
where the magnitude is
being attenuated by
whatever frequency.
So my dependence of 1 over
k becomes 1 over k squared,
and it goes from being a
square wave to a triangle wave.
So that's a way of thinking
about the signal transformation
in terms of a filter.
We did that last time.
What's going on with speech
is exactly the same thing.
What we want to do
is think about--
the glottis makes some kind of
a sound that goes into a filter.
The filter is this
thing that is controlled
by my tongue's
position and my jaw
position and my lip position
and stuff like that.
And what comes out is speech.
To demonstrate
that, here's a film
that was made by Ken Stevens.
Ken Stevens was a professor
in this department.
He just recently retired.
This was done when he
was a graduate student.
It's very hard to see because
the contrast is not great.
But you have to take
into consideration
this was made with X-rays.
OK, we probably
wouldn't do this today.
It was a relatively
large exposure
to x-rays, which we sort
of frown on these days.
Just so you're not too worried,
Ken Stevens, when he retired,
had the longest teaching
career in our history.
He was a lecturer who actively
lectured for 50 years.
So he seemed to have done OK.
He survived.
So you don't need to worry
about what happened to him.
But we probably
wouldn't repeat this.
It's a little hard to see.
The bone is easy, right,
because x-rays don't
go through bones very well.
What you can just
barely see is his lips.
And it's important to
watch the lips, too.
It's also important that
his chin is on a chin rest
to simplify analysis.
The idea of this was to get
quantitative measurements
to fit the source filter idea.
OK, so now I'm going to play
a film, a recording of him.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Test.
Test.
[? The tongue. ?]
The [INAUDIBLE].
The [INAUDIBLE]..
[? The neck. ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
[INAUDIBLE]
[? Fox. ?] [? Clock. ?]
The [INAUDIBLE]..
The [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
[? Took. ?] [? Two. ?]
[INAUDIBLE]..
[? Tot. ?] [? Tech. ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
Why did [INAUDIBLE] set the
[INAUDIBLE] on top of his desk?
I have put [? blood under ?]
[? two clean ?]
[? yellow shoes. ?]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK, so what
you were supposed to see
is that the thing that
we associate with speech
is only a small part of it.
His lips were obviously moving.
That's what we see.
But if you were
paying attention,
his tongue was going up and down
not a little bit, but a lot.
So the gap between his tongue
and the roof of his mouth
was going from 0
to about that far.
The velum back here was opening
very broadly on occasion.
So there was a
significant variation
in the shape of the structure
through which the glottis wave
form was passing.
And that's the basis of the
filtering that gives rise
to the different speech sounds.
So to convince you
of that, here I
have a carefully machined item.
Let's see.
I don't want this one.
I want this one.
So this is a Japanese oo.
OK, now I don't know Japanese,
so I have to just sort of trust
the guy who made
this that it actually
sounds like a Japanese oo.
The second one I'll show is
a Japanese ee, which actually
sounds more like an ee to me.
But anyway, this model was made
from measurements of the type
that I just showed with Ken.
So the idea was to estimate
the size of those cavities
through which the
air was passing,
and then make, by
machining in Plexiglas,
a structure that has that shape.
So this was an early test
of whether the source filter
idea works.
So if that is the explanation
for how speech is generated,
then I ought to be able
to take a boring sound
of the type that's
generated by the glottis--
[BUZZING SOUND]
And put it through this, and it
should sound more like a vowel.
OK?
Got it?
Know what I'm talking about?
So this is a Japanese oo.
[BUZZING SOUND]
[COMBINES BUZZING SOUND WITH
'OO' SOUND]
I don't know if
anybody knows Japanese.
I don't know if that
sounds like an oo.
Does anybody know
Japanese, and does that
sound like an oo or not?
OK, I'll pass.
[BUZZING SOUND]
This is an ee.
OK, now notice that the
ee looks very different.
Right?
The question is whether
that's a big enough difference
to make the difference
between an oo and an ee.
I'm pressing the same button,
nothing up my sleeve, nothing--
OK, so same button.
[COMBINES BUZZING SOUND WITH
'EE' SOUND]
OK, so what you're
supposed to be convinced of
is there is enough
information in the shape
of the vocal
structures to account
for the difference
in the sounds.
Now of course, we don't really
care about the acoustics
if we're trying to, for example,
synthesize or analyze speech.
We don't particularly
care about that.
We do like to know that there
is a theory that underlies it,
right?
And there's a very
sound physical basis
for why we should think
about the source filter idea.
When I say source
filter, source filter--
so everybody calls it the
source filter model of speech.
So is there any
good physical reason
for why that should be true?
Of course, what we care about
is the frequency response.
So here what's showed
is measurements
of frequency responses
taken from speakers.
So now we don't do
the x-ray thing.
All we do is record somebody
saying heed, had, hood,
haw'd, who'd.
And we look at men,
women, and children,
and we characterize how their
frequency responses change
when they make those
different sounds.
So what's showed here is that
you get a relatively good fit
by thinking about the frequency
response having three formants.
The formants are the
peak frequencies.
There's a theory,
which I won't go into,
for how you take this
shape and turn it
into a formant frequency.
And given just the formant
frequencies, or given
the frequency response
measured at uniform spacing
across frequencies,
there is a theory
for how you can generate the
smooth line, which is really--
this is an 11th order
[? fit, ?] which
means that there are
11 poles and no zeros.
So what you do to
get this shape then
is take the locations
and amplitudes
of the formant frequencies
and do a fit using poles.
And so here's a table showing
measured formant frequencies,
F1, F2, and F3, for
whatever, six different
sounds for three different
categories of speakers.
OK?
And that's kind of a complete
analysis then in terms
of the source filter idea.
So this figure
summarizes the idea.
We think about source filters.
So the source is the glottis.
The filter is the formants
created by the throat.
And speech is the thing that
comes out of the source filter.
The source is some
periodic waveform
caused by the banging
together of the vocal folds.
The filter is the frequency
response of the throat.
And the result, then, is just
passing this glottis wave
form-- so this is a measured--
by sticking a microphone
in somebody's throat,
this is a measurement of what
the glottis acoustics looks
like.
This is a Fourier decomposition
of that periodic waveform.
Then this is the frequency
response of that thing.
And this is the
Fourier coefficients
of the output for
different sounds.
So here is the frequency.
So the same glottis signal
underlies and ee sound and ah
sound and generates
two different spectra.
We call that combination
of magnitudes and angles.
We call that the
Fourier spectrum.
So you get two
different spectra,
depending on the filter shape.
OK?
And that's the basis--
this theory, this
source filter idea--
is the basis of the
current technology
for speech recognition
and speech production.
So I actually cheated.
Those sounds that
I played earlier--
bit, bat, bought, beat,
all those things--
those were actually
synthetic speech.
OK, all I did is I ran
a speech synthesizer,
and I said, synthesize bit.
So that was really
a synthesized thing.
That was not a real person.
And so the synthesizer
used this theory
in order to generate
this synthetic speech.
We also use this theory in
order to recognize speech.
And you'll do a homework
problem in Homework 10,
I think it is, in which you'll
build the primitive front
end of a speech recognizer
using this theory.
And I'll give you a couple of
utterances of different vowels
and you'll have to classify
which vowel is being said,
according to some
automatic speech recognizer
based on this theory.
The theory is also just
fun, because a theory
lets us figure out anomalies.
So when somebody has
a speech impediment,
for example, when I did, when
I was a little kid I did.
And I was sent to speech school.
Now they do a much
better job because they
do analysis to figure
out what I'm doing wrong,
using this sort of
source filter idea.
We can also use the
source filter idea
to understand paradoxes.
So for example, I've told you
before I work on hearing aids.
I tried to make
hearing aids hear.
And so people with hearing
deficiencies like mine,
where I have sort of
progressive age-related
because I'm old, right,
that's what happens.
I have age-related
hearing loss, which
means that I'm losing
high frequencies.
I'm less sensitive
to high frequencies.
People like me, which is
the vast majority of people
my age--
it's easier to understand male
speech than female speech.
Why?
Higher frequencies.
So those higher
frequencies shift
some of the important
stuff that I
should be listening
to into frequencies
I don't hear anymore.
Right?
So that's a way of
using this theory
to try to understand
what's wrong with me.
But there's also things--
it's not just me.
Normal people have trouble
distinguishing female speech,
especially in taxing
environments, and one of those
is singing.
So if you consider
altos and sopranos,
sopranos are like,
the worst, right?
Because they are not only
female, but they're at the high
end the females.
And there are those
who complain about not
being able to understand
female singers.
OK, so here's a
demo that will help
us to understand whether that's
a valid kind of a criticism
or not.
So what I've got is
a professional singer
singing, la, la, la, la--
on a scale.
So from low frequency
to high frequency,
then a different sound,
a different sound,
a different sound.
So the first thing
that I want to do--
I want you to listen to
those different sounds
as she goes across the scale.
Then I'm going to play
just the low ones and just
the high ones, just the
low frequency ones and just
the high frequency ones.
So first, the different scales--
la, la, lore, loo, lee, OK?
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- La, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la.
La.
Lore, lore, lore, lore, lore,
lore, lore, lore, lore, lore,
lore, lore, lore,
lore, lore, lore, lore.
Lore.
Loo, loo, loo, loo, loo, loo,
loo, loo, loo, loo, loo, loo,
loo, loo, loo, loo.
Loo.
Ler, ler, ler, ler, ler, ler,
ler, ler, ler, ler, ler, ler,
ler, ler, ler, ler.
Ler.
Lee, lee, lee, lee, lee, lee,
lee, lee, lee, lee, lee, lee,
lee, lee, lee, lee.
Lee.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK, so
now what I've done
is I've sliced out the lowest
frequency, the very first
of the scale from
each of the sounds
and pasted them together to
get the low frequency run.
And then I took out the high
ones and pasted them together.
OK?
Exactly the same sounds, just
played in a different order.
So first the low frequency ones.
SINGER: La.
Lore.
Loo.
Ler.
Lee.
And the high frequency ones.
La.
Lore.
Loo.
Ler.
Lee.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: It's not her fault.
She's doing everything right.
And you can see that.
Here is, again, a Python program
analyzing those same segments.
So what's shown here is the ee,
the filter derived from the ee,
by thinking about the lee,
lee, lee, lee, lee, lee--
by looking at that
sequence, and averaging
across the frequencies.
So here's the filter.
Here's the filtered glottis
spectrum for a low frequency
and intermediate frequency
and high frequency.
What's the difference between
the low, middle, and high?
What's characteristically
different at low and high?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
frequency, like high amplitude.
PROFESSOR: So if you look at the
low frequency, the low pitch,
there are more frequency
components in a given range.
So if I say analyze the
frequencies between 0
and 1,000 hertz, 1,000
cycles per second,
there are more lines when
you have a low frequency.
And so you get the
density of the lines
is greater for the low
frequency utterance
than it is for the high
frequency utterance.
The low frequency utterance
is spaced close enough
that you can clearly figure out
this pattern from that spacing,
because there are
multiple lines per peak.
The problem is that
the speech waveforms
have very sharp resonances.
The peaks are narrow.
So that as you go to
a higher frequency,
now it's very hard to see.
So where there was two lines
characterizing this guy,
now there's one.
And at the highest frequency,
there's nothing there.
Similarly with these
peaks, again, several lines
representing each peak.
One line representing-- nothing
representing this peak, nothing
representing that peak.
There is nothing about
ee in that signal.
And if you do the
same analysis for ah,
you get the same result.
There's nothing about ee,
and there's nothing about ah.
There's just nothing there.
There's no way anybody is going
to tell those two sounds apart.
So if the singer put her
voice, her vocal tract,
in precisely the
right location, there
would be no difference
between those sounds,
OK, regardless of what
the director said.
OK, so that's the problem.
So that's a way of
using the Fourier
analysis to gain some insight
into some anomalous situations.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this
have more to do
with the rate at
which you're sampling?
PROFESSOR: No.
It has to do only with
the frequency content
of the glottis waveform.
You can think about
it as sampling.
And that's a good insight,
because the Fourier series only
has components at integer
multiples of a base frequency.
So that means we're sampling
in frequency, not in time.
So we have this potentially
continuous frequency response,
which is characterizing this.
That is continuous.
I could excite this at any
frequency that I want to.
But the glottis
waveform of the singer
is only sampling that at
particular frequencies--
C, C prime, C double prime, B,
B prime, B double prime, right?
So there's only certain
frequencies at which
the singer is sampling this.
So there is a way of thinking
about it as sampling.
But it's not sampling
due to my ADD converter
or anything like that.
It's sampling in frequency.
So the point is that this
kind of a source filter idea,
and more generally,
the filter idea,
is such a powerful
representation
that next time we'll
think about how
to do the same sort of thing
for non-periodic [? stimuli. ?]
See you then.